but we do have another player with us
Jennifer the defending Champion Jennifer
you is with us welcome to the show how
are you feeling about this game a very
tense finished in a draw but I have to
say it could have gone either
way yeah um well I have to I don't
really know what was going on in the
middle there but at some point I felt
like going into the end game I was
definitely very comfortable better um so
I might have misplayed that part but we
were kind of scrambling the time but you
know I felt pretty comfortable
throughout like this game like I was
never really worried too much I just
definitely could have improved but you
know it I feel pretty nonchalant about
this game you know it's so a draw is
still a good result still just the first
game plenty of time to uh not
necessarily catch up with the leaders
because there's only one leader that's
nazzi pises is's the only one that won
in the first round but how are you
feeling about your form coming into this
event we know that you're you're a
student as well at one of the most
prestigious uh universities in the world
Harvard if I'm not mistaken sure so how
is that balancing academics with chess
and with preparation for such a
tournament uh yeah that's something I'm
definitely continuously working on um
it's not easy and Y I'm honestly I I say
that I'm like okay with this game cuz I
think like I missplay a little bit part
of it but I know I'm pretty happy with
the fact that there wasn't anything too
crazy that I did that was just
unreasonable just because you know I
haven't I haven't competed in a in a
minute and um so I was a little worried
about like the first game or something
just because sometimes it takes a little
bit of time to warm up but you know we
got this one out of the way I feel much
better now we can we can just focus on
the rest of the tournament but yeah um
it's not easy I definitely have to keep
um you know keep up with my school work
so that's what I'm going to do later
after this for a good game keep up the
uh High Spirits keep up the energy and
we'll see
tomorrow great and that leaves us